[Music]
hey guys it's Alicia Malone and there
are so many great indie films out this
week that I want to tell you about here
on Fandango indie movie Guide so I'm
gonna rush through them but let's start
off with colossal this is one of my
favorite films that I've seen this year
it's directed by nacho Vigeland oh and
it stars and Hathaway like you've never
seen her before
it is a monster kaiju movie on one hand
and on the other hand it is a drama
about a woman who is trying to overcome
the beast within which is alcohol it's
about the monster that we become when
we're drunk and most importantly it's
about breaking the cycle of abusive
relationships and falling for these
people who seem nice but in the end they
are the gigantic terrifying monster that
is looming over you and using you for
fun right
it's this nervous tic I have think of
the sitch
and Hathaways absolutely brilliant in
this role and she's also one of the
executive producers also stars Jason
Sudeikis it's funny it's smart highly
recommend you watching colossal out in
theaters this weekend she's the monster
[Music]
now to a Japanese anime called your name
I have been waiting for this movie to
come out for a long time it's been out
in the UK for a while Japan it in really
well and everybody's been telling me you
have to see your name and I'm so glad I
did it is a beautiful movie both in the
way the anime looks and the emotions
that it will elicit it's directed by
Makoto Shinkai and it's essentially a
body swap romance drama it's about these
two teenagers who wake up in each
other's bodies and they swap back and
forth and they have to figure out
exactly what is going on there's much
more to the plot than that but I don't
want to spoil anything for you this is a
real treat to look at it it has the
usual funny moments that happen in body
swap films where they wake up and
they're like whoa hang on I am a boil
I'm a girl but beyond that they form
this really deep connection by trying to
figure out who each other is and how
they can get to each other definitely
see your name it is now out in limited
theaters
on to a movie called their finest this
is a world war two film directed by lone
sure fake there was one of the dogma 95
movement members that's the Danish film
movement that relied on a lot of natural
light and natural acting and no costumes
and stripping all that artifice away
this is not that film at all this is
very beautifully shot low-budget but it
looks a million bucks and it really is a
tribute to filmmaking it's set in London
in 1940 where a young woman Katrin Cole
played by Gemma Arterton becomes a
screenwriter basically because all the
guys are gone and they start to work on
a world war two propaganda film I'm
Catherine Cole I'm one of the writers
Katrin between us will have them weeping
in the aisle
very funny moments where they delve into
how certain effects were made before
computer-generated effects were a thing
and I like catrin's character she is a
very quietly assertive woman but for the
times I think that makes complete sense
sam claflin plays the writer that she's
working with and Bill Nighy is fantastic
as this washed-up actor who still wants
to be treated like a star it's a comedy
it's a romance it's a drama it's a
lovely way to spend an afternoon check
out their finest in theaters this
weekend given opportunities only because
young men are gone but to turn our back
on those opportunities
wouldn't that be giving death dominion
over life do you really have to smoke
that thing no I mean couldn't you just
mine
I can mine smoking I can't mine smoke
and on to vampires now with a vampire
movie called the Transfiguration what a
vampire is like I think it starts with
drinking blood all you ever need to
eventually that's not good enough so you
switch the animals people
it's an American movie it's all set in
New York and it's about a guy who is a
vampire I think he might not actually be
a vampire he might just be obsessed with
vampires and kind of a murderer he might
need blood to survive or he might
actually be making himself sick because
he's taking the blood this is what I
love about indie films because you can
take a huge concept like vampires which
have been done in blockbuster levels and
strip it down the Transfiguration will
keep you transfixed the whole way try to
see it in theaters this weekend I know
it won't be playing everywhere but it is
worth a watch
and last but not least a Romanian film
called graduation this is directed by
Christian Manju who did 4 months 3 weeks
2 days which is another excellent film
this is about a young girl and her
father her father really wants her to
succeed at school so she can get a
scholarship and go to the UK he's put
everything into making that happen
because he wants her to have a better
life than he and his wife were able to
but just before her huge exam the
daughter gets assaulted and so she's
unable to concentrate on her work it
puts her future at jeopardy so her
father decides to do whatever he can
whatever it takes to try to make his
dream for her come true it looks at
those kind of parents who push their
children into doing things that they
weren't able to do themselves and they
do it out of love but that line gets
blurred a lot of moral questions with
this one check out the graduation if you
can find it in theaters especially one
which having equal people so the
journeys into showbiz so many great
little in these view this week as I say
I hope that you can find them in
theatres if you can't then just note
them down and put them aside and when
they come out on video on demand or if
they do happen to play in a town near
you you'll know that they're worth your
time and money so go and see the monster
movie colossal the beautiful anime your
name the inspiring war movie their
finest the dark vampire movie the
Transfiguration and the complex drama
graduation just a couple for you to
watch there as always let me know what
you've been watching in the comments
below or you can tweet me at Alicia
Malone I'll see you soon right
you